Trascrizione: Cristina Mancuso
Revisore: Giorgia Zanfardin
Luce.
Una semplice parola,
dietro cui si nascondono
molti più significati
di quelli che noi immaginiamo essere
il semplice frutto
tra un interruttore e una lampadina.
La luce veste la nostra vita ogni giorno,
dall'alba al tramonto.
E anche di notte è presente,
con il suo vestito più elegante
che noi chiamiamo buio.
È talmente vitale il legame che ci unisce
che è entrata a far parte
della nostra vita, del nostro linguaggio.
Non diciamo forse: "È venuto alla luce",
"Mi si è accesa la lampadina",
"Ho perso il lume della ragione"
o "Si è spento"?
L'intero arco della nostra vita
è scandito dall'alternarsi
della luce con il buio,
che insieme all'ombra e alla penombra
non sono altro che prospettive
diverse della luce.
Buio e luce, per poter essere colte
nel loro più profondo significato
vanno messe in relazione
nella loro reciprocità,
così come accade per spazio e tempo,
tra vuoto e pieno, tra pausa e azione.
Ecco svelata la complicità
della luce e del buio:
la luce del giorno ci svela
ciò che noi non possiamo
vedere con la notte,
e la notte corregge
quello che la luce non può nascondere.
Là, sospesa nel buio da cui ha origine,
evoca emozioni.
Chi di noi non ha mai provato un'emozione,
non ha mai ricordato scene di vita vissuta
davanti ad un tramonto, a un'alba,
a una luce che filtra dalle finestre?
Non ha addirittura sentito sapori?
La luce del giorno, del sole,
ci aiuta a fare conoscenza della realtà,
della maestosità che ci circonda.
Incontra i nostri occhi,
ci permette di avere uno sguardo
su ciò che senza di lei
sarebbe una massa incolore.
Sì perché è proprio grazie alla luce,
che noi vediamo i colori.
E che grazie ai colori
anche la forma più banale
diventa un'opera d'arte.
Ma se della luce del sole
noi non riusciamo più a cogliere
il senso profondo del suo esistere,
della luce artificiale,
beh, noi abbiamo un concetto un po' strano
perché è subordinato, confinato
ad un interruttore
che abbiamo in casa nostra,
attraverso il quale
noi esercitato un grande potere:
accendere o spegnere la luce.
Tuttavia la luce,
come fosse una persona saggia,
non si offende.
Rimane ferma lì,
ci custodisce, ci protegge.
Sì, lo so, qualcuno di voi
potrà dirmi: "Questa è poesia!"
No, questa è un modo alternativo
per parlare di scienza
e di medicina, in particolare,
perché, sapete, sul ruolo
che la luce riveste
ogni giorno nella nostra vita,
sul fatto che stimoli e attivi
complessi processi biologici
che ci aiutano a rimanere in salute,
perché attivano importanti funzioni vitali
come la temperatura corporea,
come la pressione sanguigna
o diversamente anche come
il nostro stato umorale.
Ebbene, sappiate che nel 2017
due persone, due studiosi hanno ricevuto,
come riconoscimento, il Premio Nobel.
Quando mi è stato chiesto
di venire qui a parlarvi,
in questa magnifica cornice che per me
rappresenta un tuffo nel passato,
bene, parlare della luce
in questo contesto
è equivalso ad avere un buio totale.
Ma non perché non avessi
nulla da raccontarvi,
ma semplicemente perché mi ero accorto
di come la prospettiva
da cui lo avrei fatto
era totalmente diversa.
Infatti non avrei parlato,
come spesso accade, con la luce,
ma avrei dovuto parlare della mia amica,
di una mia compagna di viaggio,
di quello che è lei,
di quello che voi conoscete
e di quello che, spesso,
tutti quanti ignoriamo.
Nel destino di ciascuno
di noi è custodito,
o meglio, nel nome di ciascuno di noi,
è custodico il suo destino.
E quello della luce è mostrarsi.
Delle tre dimensioni che caratterizzano
ogni oggetto della nostra vita,
la luce ne ha quattro.
Infatti accanto all'altezza,
alla profondità, la lunghezza,
ha il dono del tempo.
Sì, perché lo scandisce,
e soprattutto lo evoca
grazie alle sue temperature
di colore, colore e luce.
Ma di che colore è la luce?
La luce non ha un colore.
La luce è il colore.
Ed è l'incontro tra i sette colori
che noi vediamo dipinti nel cielo
dopo un temporale estivo,
o aggrappati a una cascata
quando la luce del sole
decide di incontrare l'acqua nebulizzata.
Ma la tecnologia ci viene in aiuto,
perché quei fari che sono montati
su molte delle vostre auto, allo xenon,
ci permettono di incontrarlo
e di capire che il suo colore
non è giallo, come noi lo immaginavamo
e lo disegnavano sui banchi di scuola.
Non è bianco, come noi
l'abbiamo immaginato fino ad oggi.
Ma è di un bianco tendente all'azzurro.
E grazie al suo colore,
grazie alla sua composizione,
quella luce ci regala l'azzurro del cielo,
ci regala la magia
delle albe e dei tramonti
e ci restituisce quello che è
il colore del cielo, di notte:
il nero.
Questa è la luce del sole.
Accanto abbiamo la luce degli uomini,
che spesso pensano che illuminare
sia inondare uno spazio di luce.
Ma così facendo, la luce,
come se fosse una persona,
urla, acceca, abbaglia, brucia,
appiattisce ogni prospettiva,
toglie emozioni.
La luce, in realtà, è come se fosse
la musica in un piano bar.
Accompagna una conversazione,
custodisce delle emozioni.
La luce non brucia, scalda.
La luce non urla, sussurra;
la luce non spaventa, rincuora.
Chi degli uomini ha intuito
il valore e il linguaggio della luce
ha reso più confortevoli i luoghi
in cui noi ci muoviamo,
ha cominciato a parlare con noi
in maniera silenziosa
e ha aumentato la redditività
del suo business.
Ma pensate: questa non è
la luce più importante.
La luce più importante, e quella
da cui tutte le luci hanno origine,
è quella che custodite dentro di voi.
È una luce che noi teniamo spenta,
per la paura che ci faccia vedere
cose che non vogliamo,
che teniamo nascosta
per la paura che qualcuno la spenga.
La storia dell'uomo si è interrogata
su quale sia il valore
della luce invisibile.
La risposta è sempre stata più di una,
ma tutte quante dicono la stessa cosa:
la luce è conoscenza,
è rivelazione di un mistero
che ovviamente noi non conosciamo.
È il mostrare ciò che è nascosto,
ma soprattutto, è svelare
che quello che non si vede,
non sempre non esiste.
È questa la luce che io amo.
Quella che mi aiuta ad entrare in contatto
con le opere dell'ingegno
e della creatività che devo illuminare,
perché attraverso quella luce
ascolto il racconto
di chi ha creato quelle opere.
Ascolto la loro passione,
e a me rimane la responsabilità
di tradurre quelle emozioni
con il fascino che la luce ha
anche quando è tramontata
oltre la linea dell'orizzonte.
Per questo definisco la mia attività
come una "sartoria di luce",
che produce emozioni sotto forma di luce
perché racconta storie,
evocando il tempo che fu nel tempo,
quando quelle opere
sono diventate patrimonio di tutti.
È questo modo di concepire la luce
che mi permette di parlare
della luce del design.
La luce del design
è quella che crea sculture di luce
che si plasmano su strutture esistenti
o che scolpiscono spazi vuoti,
regalandogli una forma,
regalandogli la vita.
Portando la speranza
anche dove grida un buio dolore.
Pensate alle Torri Gemelle, a New York.
In questo gioco,
tutti gli elementi coinvolti
si fondono gli uni con gli altri,
creando un'emozione che è la stessa
che voi potete incontrare
nello sguardo di chi osserva
il miracolo di quell'unione.
Poi c'è il design della luce,
quello che è un puro esercizio di stile,
dove la forma diventa sostanza,
dove la luce non può, in alcun modo,
declinare se stessa.
Mostrare e non mostrarsi.
Da oggi, mi auguro,
che accendere una luce a casa vostra
non sia più la stessa cosa.
Da oggi mi auguro che quell'interruttore
sia una porta su di un nuovo mondo,
un nuovo universo: quello della luce.
In cui, però, vi invito
a non essere più inconsapevoli passeggeri
ma attenti e motivati viaggiatori.
Per questo sono certo
che davanti a qualsiasi evento
fotograferà la vostra vita,
che si tratti di un'alba,
che si tratti di un sole
che filtra dalle finestre,
che si tratti di una cena
a lume di candela o di un tramonto,
voi abbiate sempre
a domandarvi e a ripetervi:
"E poi la chiamano solo luce!"
Grazie.
(Applausi)